[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
hallweg guten Abend schön dass Sie dabei
sind wie auch Katja streso für den Sport
auch von mir einen schönen guten Abend
wir haben unter anderem diese Themen für
Sie EU-Gipfel im krisenmodus neue
Uneinigkeit über den narostkompromiss
und auch die 50 Milliarden Hilfe für die
Ukraine birgt Zündstoff
die Zerstörung nach dem Sturm Hurrican
Otis hinterlässt in der mexikanischen
Touristenmetropole akapulco ein riesiges
Trümmerfeld leinel Feininger in der
Frankfurter Schirn eine Großausstellung
mit 160 Arbeiten des deutsch-amerikaners
zeigt auch bisher kaum bekannte
Werke ein EU-Gipfel im Schatten von zwei
Kriegen trotz Dissonanzen gab es eine
gemeinsame Erklärung zu Nahost darin
unterstreichen die Staats- und
Regierungschefs das Recht Israels zur
Selbstverteidigung sie fordern aber
humanitäre Korridore für
Hilfslieferungen in den
Gazastreifen Streit gab es über weitere
Gelder für die Ukraine da stellen sich
Ungarn und die Slowakei quer aus Brüssel
Florian
Neuhann der Tag in Brüssel beginnt mit
einem fröhlichen selfie sie stehen
zusammen so sieht es zunächst aus auch
mit dem Kompromiss zum Nahen Osten aus
der Nacht da hatte Europa auf eine
Formel geeinigt man fordert humanitäre
Korridore Pausen bei Angriffen für
humanitäre Zwecke doch am Nachmittag
zeigt sich jeder legt diesen Kompromiss
anders aus da wird etwa der spanische
Ministerpräsident gefragt ob Israel
derzeit seiner Ansicht nach in Gaza das
humanitäre recht
einhalte ich glaube daran dürfen wir
alle Zweifel haben nach den Bildern des
Leids und der Vertreibung von über einer
Million
g seit
Wochen seit gleich ein anderer Saal und
vom deutschen Kanzler das genaue
Gegenteil Israel über hier sein Recht
auf Selbstverteidigung aus sagt Olaf
Scholz natürlich geht es immer darum das
dann auch entlang der Regelung zu machen
die zu beachten sind und wie ich schon
gesagt habe bin ich ganz sicher dass
Israel das auch tun wird Europa
diskutiert also weiter auch über andere
Themen Ukraine der Gipfel sichert dem
Land zwar langfristige Unterstützung zu
doch konkrete Gelder blockiert eher
Ungarns Ministerpräsident Viktor Orban
zum Ärger vieler anderer wir sollen
nicht hier Geisen sein auch von von mer
Orban und werden ich bin schon überzeugt
positive Lösungen finden eine positive
Lösung für den Nahen Osten könnte das
sagen Sie hier eine europäische
Friedenskonferenz sein zumindest dazu
gab es heute keine zwei
Interpretationen
Ulf Röller in Brüssel was ist diese
gemeinsame Erklärung zu Israel wert wenn
sie sofort unterschiedlich interpretiert
wird also wenn man das ganz offen und
sehr hart sagt ist sie eigentlich nicht
viel wert es ist doch sehr erstaunlich
dass man nach einem nicht mal einen Tag
schon wieder auf öffentlicher Bühne
streitet und uneinig ist Europa will in
der Region ernst genommen werden im
Nahen Osten aber so verliert Europa an
Glaubwürdigkeit es gibt eine Gruppe und
die wird größer die sehr sehr kritisch
gegenüber Israel ist und immer wieder
sagt diese Blockaden des Gazastreifens
gehen überhaupt nicht und sie waren
davor auch vor einer Bodenoffensive weil
das unheimlich viele zivile Opfer
bringen könnte ganz voran der
französische Präsident franis macron und
es muss Deutschland quasi seine gesamte
Autorität einsetzen damit die Kritik an
Israel nicht noch lauter wird Fazit die
EU würde gerne im nostkonflikt
vermitteln und eine Lösung finden aber
sie hat eigentlich nicht mal ihren
eigenen nostkonflikt im Griff danke
schön für diese Einschätzung aus Brüssel
Ulf
Röller israel hat auf die Forderungen
der EU bislang nicht offiziell reagiert
bekommt aber auch Druck aus den USA sich
an die Regeln des Krieges zu halten
ungeachtet seines Rechts auf
Selbstverteidigung nach Angaben der
Terrororganisation Hamas ist die Zahl
der Toten im Gazastreifen auf
7300 gestiegen überprüfbar sind diese
Zahlen nicht und auch die Hamas schickt
weitere
Israel
ker seit di Wochen hält der Krieg die
Regionen Atem und ein Ende ist nicht
absehbar auch heute wieder schwere
Luftangriffe der israelischen
Streitkräfte immerhin so das Rote Kreuz
haben heute wieder hilfslastwagen und
ein Ärzteteam den Gazastreifen erreicht
das un Hilfswerk für Palästina warnt
dennoch vor einem Zusammenbruch der
öffentlichen Ordnung es fehle an fast
allen
Hilfsgütern Krankenhäuser Schulen
uninrichtungen wo tausende nach
Sicherheit suchen müssen respektiert
werden das israelische Militär aber
wirft der Hamas vor unter anderem
Krankenhäuser als Schutzschilde zu
benutzen in der größten Klinik im
Gazastreifen dem Schiefer Krankenhaus
bewege sich die Hamas frei und betreibe
kommandozellen von hier aus befehlen sie
Raketenangriffe und führen hamaskräfte
die Terroristen operieren im und unter
dem Schifer Krankenhaus und in anderen
in Gaza vernetzt durch
Tunnel offenbar gehen auch die
israelischen Bodenoperationen im
Gazastreifen weiter Einheiten sein in
der vergangenen Nacht erneut
vorübergehend mit Panzern und
Luftunterstützung einmarschiert so das
israelische Militär in Tel Aviv gab es
heute Mittag mehrfach Luftalarm eine
Rakete aus Gaza schlug in einem Wohnhaus
ein vier Menschen wurden
verletzt das ist sehr erschreckend wir
fühlen uns unsicher in einer Stadt die
die sicherste der Welt sein
sollte in Jerusalem gedachten gestern
Menschen mit einer Lichtinstallation der
von der Hamas verschleppten Geiseln laut
einer aktuellen Umfrage sagen
mittlerweile knapp die Hälfte der
Israelis es wäre besser mit einer
Bodenoffensive zu
warten tja seit fast dii Wochen müssen
die Angehörigen der Geiseln die
Ungewissheit ertragen Michael bwerunge
in tilaviv die israelische Armee
korrigiert auch immer wieder die Zahl
der entführten nach oben heute auf zwei
9 wie ist das zu
erklären das hat zwei Gründe zum einen
sind noch längst nicht alle Toten
identifiziert das ist unglaublich
schwierig viele Körper sind unglaublich
verstimmelt teilweise verbrannt das geht
nur noch über DNA Test und man muss
natürlich wissen wer ist tot und wer
gehört zu den Geiseln dazu ist auch die
Zahl der Vermissten unklar nicht alle
die als Geiseln gekippptnett wurden
haben Verwandte das teilweise zugereist
es waren teilweise Gastarbeiter das
heißt diese Zahl ist auch noch nicht
genau bestimmt hinter mir demonstrieren
auf jeden Fall jeden Tag an die hunderte
heute sind es weniger weil der Schabbat
bereits begonnen hat aber die Rufe
werden immer lauter und immer zorniger
viele Angehörige der Geiseln fühlen sich
von der Regierung schlecht unterrichtet
und sie kritisieren dass die Regierung
zu wenig tut auch wenn die eben in
dieser geiselfrage bei den Verhandlungen
sehr wenig tun kann wir haben es gehört
fast die Hälfte der Israelis ist
deswegen für eine Verschiebung der
Bodenoffensive um eben noch mehr für die
Freilassung der Geiseln tun zu können
danke Michael bewunge aus Tel
Aviv schon vor dem Krieg war das Leben
vieler Palästinenser geprägt von Armut
und Arbeitslosigkeit ein Teil von ihnen
hatte Jobs in Israel gefunden mehr als
190.000 Palästinenser arbeiteten nach
Angaben der UN in Israel und in den
jüdischen Siedlungen im Westjordanland
seit dem Angriff der Hamas sitzen im
Westjordanland auch tausende Arbeiter
aus Gaza fest unsere Reporterin Alisa
jung
berichtet das ist der Grenzübergang
zwischen Israel und dem Westjordanland
seit dem 7 oktober kommt fast kein
Palästinenser mehr rüber wer Arbeit in
Israel hatte steht jetzt ohne Job
da diese Situation betrifft mich sehr
sehr
sehr meine Frau ist schwanger und ich
habe Angst was ich tun soll wenn das
Kind zur Welt
kommt sie haben schon sechs Kinder Najib
alkaraki konnte als Anstreicher in
Israel viel mehr verdienen ob und wann
die Grenze wieder für alle aufgeht das
fragen sich ztausende Menschen aus dem
Westjordanland die Jobs auf der anderen
Seite haben und auch rund 18000 Menschen
aus Gaza durften zuvor legal in Israel
arbeiten nun sitzen viele wie hier in
ramala fest ihre Erlaubnis wurde
entzogen aus Angst wie es nun weitergeht
will Abu Mohammad dass wir sein Gesicht
nicht
zeigen alle diese Arbeiter haben nichts
zu tun mit dem was passiert ist das Leid
der Arbeiter ist sehr groß hier sind so
viele Menschen hier wurde uns geholfen
aber das ist kein Platz um zu
bleiben doch israel fürchtet um die
eigene Sicherheit so dürfen die Männer
hier nicht raus wir wollen nur Sie uns
zu unseren Familien nach Gaza
zurückbringen damit wir sie sehen bevor
sie sterben sie sterben dort und wir
sind hier wir wollen unsere Familien
Kinder und Frauen unklar ob und wann sie
sie
wiedersehen der Präsident des Bundesamts
für Verfassungsschutz warnt vor
gezielten Angriffen auf Jüdinnen und
Juden der Antisemitismus in Deutschland
habe ein neues Niveau erreicht im
Spiegel sprach Thomas Haldenwang von
einer zesur rund 1800 Straftaten hab es
seit den Terroranschlägen der Hamas in
diesem Zusammenhang gegeben der
Judenhass auf deutschen Straßen erinnere
so wörtlich an die schlimmsten Zeiten
der deutschen Geschichte Hass schürt
Hass und die Aggressionen spüren nicht
nur Juden sondern auch Muslime in
Nordrhein-Westfalen haben jetzt beide
Seiten ein Zeichen gesetzt und sind
aufeinander zugegangen Alexander
Schwinning Brandspuren an der Rückseite
der Bochumer mche hatten in der
vergangenen Woche versucht die Rolläden
an der Moschee anzuzünden zum Glück
vergeblich dass das Treffen zwischen
Vertretern jüdischer und muslimischer
Gemeinden jetzt ausgerechnet hier
stattfindet sei kein Zufall so der Chef
der NRW Staatskanzlei Nathanael liminski
er hatte die Idee zu den
Gesprächsrunden und ich freue mich dass
die jüdischen Gemeinden diese Einladung
angenommen haben und dass wir heute hier
in Bochum ein Zeichen setzen gegen
muslimfeindliche Gewalt ein Zeichen
dafür dass wir in diesem Land sicher und
frei zusammenleben wollen unabhängig von
der Religion schon am Montag hatte sich
die Runde getroffen in einer Synagoge in
Köln das Ergebnis eine gemeinsame
Erklärung in der die greulteltaten der
herammas verurteilt werden nun also der
Gegenbesuch in Bochum bis auf die
unterste Ebene so der Vorsitzende der
jüdischen Gemeinde Köln sollen die
Mitglieder der islamischen Gemeinden
wissen dass ihre Anführer die Anschläge
in Israel
ablehnen das halte ich halten wir
eminent wichtig weil dann erreichen wir
wirklich dass eine Veränderung in der
Gesellschaft stattfinden kann was
Toleranz für andere Religionen angeht
die Gespräche und einen Rundgang durch
die Moschee fanden hinter verschlossenen
Türen statt Kameras mussten draußen
bleiben die muslimischen Verbände finden
im Anschluss klare Worte wir wollen auch
dass dann dieser Krieg schnell wie
möglich beendet wird weil es sterben
Leute ist egal von welchem Land von
welcher Nationalität welche Religion
stammt die Gespräche sollen fortgesetzt
werden auf Verbandsebene und in den
Gemeinden ein Anfang ist
gemacht seit Monaten bewegt sich bei den
Tarifverhandlungen im Einzel sowie im
Großhandel nichts deshalb rief die
Gewerkschaft werdi heute zu Warnstreiks
auf so wie hier in Stuttgart gingen
bundesweit viele Beschäftigte auf die
Straße für den Einzelhandel fordert W
die 2,50 € mehr pro Stunde mindestens
aber einen Stundenlohn von 13,50 € für
den Großhandel wird getrennt verhandelt
die nächste Runde ist für kommende Woche
geplant nach dem gewaltsamen Tod eines
Obdachlosen in Nordrhein-Westfalen haben
Ermittler drei Jugendliche festgenommen
der 14-Jährige und die beiden
15-Jährigen stehen im Verdacht den Mann
getötet zu haben sein Leichnam war
gestern in hornbad Meinberg gefunden
worden die Jugendlichen sollen den
Obdachlosen mit Fäusten und
Messerstichen attackiert die Tat gefilmt
und später im Internet geteilt haben die
Ermittler gehen davon aus dass sie ihr
Opfer zufällig
auswählten vor zwei Tagen hat
Wirbelsturm Otis in Mexiko gewütet 27
Menschen starben starben vier werden
noch vermisst die von der Regierung
versprochene Hilfe lässt auf sich warten
um an Lebensmittel und Wasser zu kommen
plündern Einwohner Supermärkte vor allem
in akapulko an der Pazifikküste sind die
Schäden massiv viele Hotels zerstört
Claudia Bates berichtet
am Badestrand von akapulko
hotelskelette in den Hotels an der
Strandpromenade versuchen verängstigte
Touristen sich in Sicherheit zu
bringen die Fassaden viele Fenster
zerstört alles durcheinander gewirbelt
Telefon Strom Internet
zusammengebrochen wenn man sich das
anschaut ist akapulko ein totales
disaster es ist nicht mehr das was es
war der Park zerstört die Gebäude die
Straßen ich würde es als totales
disaster
beschreiben zu Fuß verlassen jetzt nach
dem Hurricane viele die Stadt
irgendwohin wo man leben kann denn in
der vorletzten Nacht war der Sturm an
Land gepeitscht mit Regenmassen und
Böhen von bis zu 330 stundenkilomet er
war schnell zu einem Hurricane der
höchsten Kategorie 5
angewachsen die Wassertemperatur im
Pazifik vor der Westküste Mexikos ist
viel höher als normalerweise zu dieser
Jahreszeit und das hat die
Voraussetzungen geschaffen dafür dass
der Sturm so intensiv
wird die Menschen haben Hunger plündern
Lebensmittel und alles andere gleich mit
die Armee rückt an das große Aufräumen
hat jetzt begonnen in
akapulko es dürfte wieder ein
Publikumsmagnet werden erstmals seit 25
Jahren zeigt die Kunsthalle Schirn eine
große Ausstellung von linel Feininger
der deutschamerikaner gehört zu den
populärsten Künstlern der klassischen
Moderne gestorben ist er
1956 eines seiner Lieblingsmotive waren
Kirchen in Frankfurt ist aber auch
Spielzeug zu sehen dass er für seine
Söhne schnitzte Andrea
Mäuser
Holzspielzeug frühe
Karikaturen
Selbstbildnisse Holzschnitte und
Fotografien leinel Feininger ein
Deutsch-Amerikaner der große Teile
seines Lebens in Deutschland verbrachte
hat all das geschaffen und jetzt will
die Schirn uns all das nahe bringen was
man bei uns entdecken kann sind die
Werke für die leinol Feininger bekannt
wurde aber vor allem auch arbeiten wie
Karikaturen seine Zeichnungen und die
Fotografien die jüngst erst entdeckt
wurden um damit den ganzen Feininger
kennenzulernen der ganze Feininger
natürlich gehört da die kleine Kirche in
gelmerroder dazu vier Jahrzehnte fünf
Bilder ein Motiv Feininger und seine
kristallinen Strukturen wie man sie
kennt Feininger wie man ihn kennenlernen
soll zeigen diese frühen Werke
figürliche Bilder Menschen und Mode
einer vergangenen Zeit gleichzeitig
humorvoll und
karikaturenhaft es sind fantastische
Szenerien wo man nicht weiß was für eine
Geschichte erzählt wird aber sie sind
wild und sehr frei aber es gibt auch
diese Seestücke ruhige Bilder von
glücklichen Stunden an der Ostsee 1937
kehrt Feininger in die USA zurück wie
die alte Heimat mit neuen Augen sieht
davon erzählen diese Bilder und die
alten Diapositive mit dem Blick aus der
Wohnung in New York sie sind das letzte
schmanal in dieser großen vielfältigen
Ausstellung und jetzt zum Fußball Bayern
Leverkusen gewinnt und gewinnt und
gewinnt Katja und gewinnt genau in der
Tat sind die Leverkusen seit 13 Spielen
nacheinander ungeschlagen gestern Abend
in der Europa League bekam Karabach
agdam das geballte Selbstbewusstsein der
Tabellenführer zu spüren 5 Z1 der
Endstand in der
BayArena Bayer Trainer schabi Alonso
lässt Florian Wirz von Anfang an Spielen
gute Idee denn Wirz trifft nach 4
Minuten zum 10 den Ausgleich durch
thoral beiramow per faulelfmeter steckt
Leverkusen leicht weg Wirz wird zum
Vorbereiter für Alejandro Grimaldo nach
einer halben Stunde und Victor bonace
erhöht noch vor der Pause auf 3 Z1
beruhigende Führung nennt man sowas das
Spiel ist keine Stunde alt da haben noch
mal Grimaldo wieder nach Vorarbeit von
Wirz und edmont tapsoba die Führung auf
5:1 ausgebaut dabei bleibt's die
torlaunigen Leverkusener sind in ihrer
Europa League Gruppe das was sie auch in
der Bundesliga sind
Spitzenreiter und dann gab es noch zwei
deutsche Siege in der europaague gewann
der SC Freiburg 3:1 bei batka topola aus
Serbien und in der Conference League
traf die Eintracht aus Frankfurt
sechsmal gegen das torlose Team aus
Helsinki morgen beginnt höchstoffiziell
die Wintersportsaison live im ZDF erst
im Livestream dann ab vi: Uhr auch im TV
mit dem Riesenslalom der Frauen in
Sölden es ist kein unumstrittener Termin
denn der voranschreitende Klimawandel
ist auch dort am Gletscher ganz klar
Thema seit 30 Jahren beginnt der Weltcup
Oktober auf dem Gletscher in Sölden
Werbung machen für den Wintersport und
für den Tourismus das ist die Idee wenn
der Winter aber immer später einzukält
scheint dieses frühe Rennen zunehmend
fehlerm Platz das sieht auch die beste
Rennläuferin aller Zeiten
so ich denke einfach die Umwelt an den
Sport anzupassen ist verkehrt das sollte
anders herum sein für Kritik haben aber
auch die Arbeiten am Gletscher im Sommer
gesorgt doch das einebenen des
Untergrundes war notwendig um darauf nun
eine Ebene Skipiste zu präparieren die
Natur nehme dadurch keinen Schaden das
Schmelzen des Gletschers bleibt davon
unberührt das hat also keine Folgen wenn
man Pisten präpariert oder auch die
Befahrung durch die Skifahrer wirkt sich
nicht negativ auf den Gletscher aus und
wenn es nur einmal schneit sieht
plötzlich doch alles nach Winter aus so
wie heute in Sölden ja und mehr zu
diesem Thema in unserer Doku Endspiel
ums Klima auf sportstudio.de oder in der
ZDF Mediathek danke schön Katja
zum Schluss etwas dass wir sonst
unbedingt vermeiden eine saualte
Geschichte sorry für die Wortwahl aber
es geht um diese rund 11000 Jahre alte
wildschweinstatue Wissenschaftler des
Deutschen Archäologischen Instituts
haben sie in der Südosttürkei
ausgegraben sicher eine Schweinearbeit
aber sie hat sich gelohnt die Forscher
fanden Farbreste zum allerersten Mal an
einer Skulptur aus dieser Epoche dass
sie all die Jahrhunderte erhalten blieb
Schwein
gehabt morgen ist es südlich der Donau
freundlich sonst ist es nass mehr hat
gleich Christ auBen um 10 begrüßt Sie
Dunja Hayali im heute journal wir sagen
danke und tschüss und bis morgen wenn
Sie mögen alles Gute
[Musik]
ihnen guten Abend langsam wird die Natur
bunt golden wie hier heute morgen bei
Erfurt golden zeigt sich der Oktober ja
aber nicht gerade sondern eher grau und
das liegt an dem Tief Zeus das ist
nämlich das steuernde tief am
Nordatlantik und das sorgt dafür dass
immer weitere Atlantik Tiefs zu uns
gelenkt werden und so setzt sich heute
Nacht das eine Regengebiet im Nordosten
fest aus Südwesten folgt dann aber schon
das nächste am ersten trocken bleibt es
nur im Südosten die Temperaturen sinken
auf 10° an nieder und an oberreihen und
auf 4° an den Alpen morgen gibt's dann
ähnliche Temperaturen wie heute am
kühlsten ist es an der Ostsee mit 9° im
Breisgau können auch 17° erreicht werden
wie der gesamte oktober wird das morgen
ein nasser Tag im Norden ist es dazu
grau bei einem nur auf der seeböhigen
östlichen Wind sonst frisch der Wind aus
Südwest auf mit stürmischen Böhen auf
den Bergen und es gibt immer mal wieder
Wolkenlücken und Regenpausen nur südlich
der Donau setzt sich längere Zeit die
Sonne durch und es bleibt trocken und
wir an den Alpen da erreichen wir
Temperaturen bis 21° am Montag mit dem
südföhen ansonsten gibt's von Westen her
aber immer neue Regengebiete das war's
von uns wir sagen
tschüss